is clearly worse for women traditional
Islamic jurist Prudence assigns very
different rights and roles to men and
women the typical woman in the
authoritarian Muslim countries generally
requires a male guardian's permission to
marry travel or work yes there's a
reason for that yeah and I can give you
a f fine example of your daughter with
all due respect your daughter for
example what as a father are you
comfortable when you first heard that
was you comfortable when Michaela came
at 16 and said I've got a boyfriend did
you feel comfortable about that I would
love to know cuz you know what I know as
a man you did not feel comfortable cuz
he was like I don't know who this man is
can I trust him what does he want for my
daughter where is he taking my daughter
what's he going to do to my daughter you
was sleeping you was losing sleep at
night your wife had to say to you she's
a grown girl don't
worry by the grace of Allah subhah wa
ta'ala the response has been
overwhelming to say the very least
alhamdulillah we've had social media
personalities and respected Scholars
from many part of the Muslim world
promoting the cause we have raised
almost 1.4 million alhamdulillah and we
haven't been sitting idy waiting to hit
our Target of 2 milon we have fully
purchased four properties in London
transferred their ownership to the W
after the help of Allah subhanahu wa
taala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves we encourage you to stay
tuned for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly
underway brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well in I'm
here with the the only
one
saor always a
pleasure I've missed our classes we need
to get back to it oh yes yes insh it was
a good excuse to see you every Thursday
alhamdulillah but brothers and sisters
we are going to be reacting to a man who
has been in rehab many times and has
come out uh this time he's come out with
a lot more nonsense doesn't look like
it's getting better um yeah it doesn't
and in fact since that last interaction
that he had with hijab in which he
couldn't even Define the basic meaning
of words and he everyone could see that
he's just hiding in vagueness and hiding
his real intentions and his real
thoughts it just goes to show that that
person's not trustworthy that they just
want to play word games and especially
since he's become a full-blown Zionist
he's decided to get rid of any residual
morality he may have had that was left
at the bottom of his shoe what do you
mean by words what you mean by gay
what do you mean by by anyways what do
you mean by Peterson yeah okay let's get
straight into in let's see what he's
doing a video about the uh the rape
gangs and the shadow of multiculturalism
so trying to make a link between
horrendous behavior and immigration
which is a far right narrative which has
just popped up interestingly after elong
musk decided that this is a really good
Avenue to attack people with oh yeah
let's watch it and let's see whose
culture uh these people see what the
arguments based on let's see where this
is coming from are most likely to bring
with them authoritarian
attitudes 24 genuine free
democracies what of the remaining 171 or
88% of the world's countries 59 of them
are fully authoritarian replete with all
the horrors such systems entail another
20 are chaotic failed States the
remainder are at best mixed bag not
fully authoritarian not entirely chaotic
but certainly not thriving
democracies and certainly not the
Western countries that the oppressed or
predatory of the world flee to given a
choice what are the cultural
preconditions for civil society and good
governance what cultural features
characterize the
24 versus the rest particularly the
worst of the rest
40 of 50 or 80% of Muslim majority
countries are fully and unabashedly
authoritarian a mere three of the
remainder are democracies Morocco turkey
and Indonesia if the definition is
allowed to be approximate and generous
the rest are at best a mixed bag and
what of majority Protestant or Catholic
countries 100% of these Africa accepted
and reasonably
so are highly functional free societies
okay PA that has to be the worst
introduction to an argument because what
you're basically doing is you're saying
this data decisive ignoring ignoring
this section ignoring the Africans like
firstly let me just be very explicitly
clear about this if you simply made the
argument without mentioning Africa it
was going to be mentioned in a rebuttal
but since you mention it that means
you're aware of how faulty this argument
is and how frankly racist it is because
we're going to talk about the Christian
country leave aside the Africans but
that if you think about there's actually
a pattern between Jordan Peterson and
the far right they do the same thing
when it comes to the grooming issue
let's not talk about the white
perpetrators focus on the pakistanis or
the Muslims or whatever you want to call
them they do the same thing it's
selective outrage when they're looking
at the numbers like okay like hello like
88% of um you know uh group sexual abuse
cases um are like white men white middle
men okay yeah I mean if we were if we
were to use this argument you know you
spoke about the majority right say m
someone like Mr Peterson his age with
his wealth with his dress sense was to
be walking around in Thailand 100% what
would people think I mean there's this
culture right there's this culture of
people going to Thailand and abusing
women and and girls and this type of
thing so let's just get past this cherry
pick because this introduction all these
countries but we've got these fantastic
24 right and these fantastic 24 they
Christian but but not these ones yeah
yeah exactly actually Russia what about
Russia that's a Christian country a huge
Christian country which is a
dictatorship he's against that uh it's
not a thriving democracy Latin America
we have Ecuador we have Honduras we have
Salvador we have Biz we have all the
Central American states we have
Venezuela we have Colombia we have
dysfunctional societies Ence in many of
these places are we going to blame
Christianity we shouldn't it's not cause
the link but look at this argument
exactly I'm going to ignore all this
data and let's just focus on this it's
selective outrage that's what it is
because they they do not care about the
crime it's not the crime the issue they
don't have an issue with the crime they
have an issue with the perpetrator and
this is what's really sickening because
we're saying we should condemn the crime
they're saying no we want to focus on
the perpetrator and we're like okay but
when we focus on the perpetrator
majority of them are white white men you
made a very powerful point and you know
one thing I'm thinking about let's think
about the victims the victim of victims
of grooming gangs or violence of any
sort by men of a Pakistani background or
whatever it is they are people who are
vulnerable they're people who we should
listen to they're people who deserve
justice those people deserve the most
severest punishment the perpetrators but
what we're being told by the far right
as you pointed out is all those other
victims whose perpetrators happen to be
white you guys you're not not as
important because your victims happen to
be white so it's an insult to the to the
victims only that it undermines and what
it does is if you think about it it is
an it is a um you are wronging these
girls who have been abused by this main
corporate because what that means is
like for example there was a lady her
name is CN and she was given she wrote a
book about it and her book was even
manipulated she said that the moment
when I me mentioned it said hold on a
second like some of or most of the the
the men who did this to me were not just
Muslim men they were like oh they were
literally insulting her kids they were
saying something the lines of like the
kids should be abused drown them what
was it drown them in the English Channel
drown them in the English Channel you're
a traitor and when when she would
mention but some of them were white
white men they like no they're just
poorly these these men it's unbelievable
they're basically propagating this fake
propaganda and anyone that talks against
it and this is a victim that's talking
they would even take her down and her
kids in the river yeah literally that's
how bad is and absolutely and if we're
going to make this argument now I
absolutely do not make a causal link
like he's trying to make linking a
particular religion to particular type
of violence but if we are to look at
certain certain things what did a
predominantly Christian Nation which he
he's trying to make an argument for what
did they basically do when it comes to
Libya what did the Italians do there
what did the French do in North Africa
what do the Russians do in caucuses what
do we find continuously if we
the Orthodox Church you're absolutely
right now we as Muslims we would never
ever blame the religion of Christianity
and try and Link it to sexual violence
and we will most certainly never try and
make it into a race issue we will take
care of the victims regardless of who
they are what he wants to do is he wants
to say some victims are more important
than others because it suits my
political agenda and my Zionist Shilling
bosses have told me this is what I need
to do yeah exactly and just like I said
to you before they just show how sick
they are it therefore seems incumbent on
those who believe that such
commensurability exists to prove that it
does particularly given the
aformentioned statistical difference
between Muslim and Christian majority
societies rather than insisting that the
burden of proof be put upon the skeptic
of the Multicultural project the
difference between the society's under
consideration bad as it is in
general is clearly worse for women
traditional Islamic Juris Prudence
assigns very different rights and roles
to men and women the typical woman in
the authoritarian Muslim countries
generally requires a male guardian's
permission to marry travel or work yes
there's a reason for that yeah and I can
give you a figh fine example of your
daughter with all due respect your
daughter for example what as a father
are you comfortable when you first heard
that your da what's the daughter's name
by the
waya Mya MAA Mya do you find it
comfortable when m Michaela that's it
Michaela would was you comfortable when
Michaela came at 16 and said I've got a
boyfriend did you feel comfortable about
that I would love to know cuz you know
what I know as a man you did not feel
comfortable cuz you was like I don't
know who this man is can I trust him
what does he want for my daughter where
is he taking my daughter what's he going
to do to my daughter you was sleeping
you was losing sleep at night your wife
had to say to you she's a grown girl
don't worry but deep down you didn't
like it now when you're talking about a
guardian over the woman folk is because
we know men can take advantage and Men
know man so on what basis and Paradigm
or what reality morality are you talking
that this is wrong you yourself would
love to live by that that a man comes to
ask for your daughter's hand in a cuz
you are um a conservative man you would
appreciate a man coming and ask him for
your daughter you you would like to be a
guardian you'd like to
be thank you not only that and I mean I
would love to know how you felt when she
flew out to see Andrew Tate and Andrew
Tate with they smirking remarks said oh
no we just drove around drove around
some random guy my daughter is flying
off to some different country with some
guy who's known to be in his previous
life and you totally disagree with him
anyway and you totally disagree with him
and he's there sitting side by side
while your daughter's in name Min please
shut up okay you know another thing I
just want you to say when you want to
bring in Islam about this in Islam if
you are going to say oh Islam has sh
Islam has this Islam has that Islam has
that rule well you have to remember two
basic things the first thing is any any
sexual misconduct that we find that's
being highlighted by the fire is totally
condemned by Islam in in fact in Islam
to touch a woman even consensually and
that woman is not someone that you're
married to is something that is hugely
sinful so if you're going to bring in
Islam don't just cherry pick secondly
when it came to testimony we know in
Islam if there's a woman who's been a
who's been subjected to some form of
sexual violence that her testimony will
put that person away and could
potentially have that person executed so
let's not cherry pick here because what
we're finding with him is he thinks he's
going to impress his brain dead
followers by saying the word shur oh he
knows a bit of Arabic shur it's like
come on BR please their inheritance
share is lesser typically Half Men can
divorce unilaterally with EAS well women
cannot okay so first thing we can point
out that he's he's totally he doesn't
what he's talking about because we know
in the Shar there's 16 instances where a
woman gets paid more than a man that's
number one yes and number two when it
comes to inheritance uh the the brother
the sister gets half of the brother yes
and that's because the man is the
protector like you talked about the
guardian he's the one that's the
protector and the provider he's the one
that's going to be providing for his
wife his daughter and potentially his
mother if his father passed away so what
we're saying is that that is the reason
why it's it's it's being um done in that
way yeah now let's just let's just take
what he's saying how on Earth is that
linked to this sexual misconduct and
this rape and this disgusting stuff
that's been happening there is no cause
of Link but what you're trying to do is
just like you ignored the Africans
you're ignoring masses of data simply
because because it suits your narrative
exactly the reason what he's doing is
he's trying to say look they're
dehumanizing their woman but this is all
propaganda and lies divorce then why
don't you go to your friend Ben Shapiro
with the scumbag dirt bag and ask his
wife go to his wife and say if Ben
doesn't divorce
you can you get a divorce she'll say to
you no Mrs Mr Jordan yes I can't I am
married him to death do a part Lally no
she's going to say what do you mean by
divorce what do you mean by Ben she
Shiro he's not even a
man okay so she cannot get a divorce in
Islam in the in Judaism it's called a
get it's quite actually funny how ironic
it's yeah it's called a get she cannot
get a get unless he gives it if he
doesn't give her a get she is stayed
married to him and cannot move on now he
talked
about he talked about a woman a man has
a right to divorce in Islam but not a
woman that was actually stipulated IM
talks about this this was stipulated
why because in Jia in the time of pagan
Pagan Arabia what happen is when a man
would divorce his wife he would
unlimited times take her back I divorce
you I take you back Islam said no free
limits what does this mean on the third
time he gives that talak that woman has
a right to fully go about her life and
choose to get married again that is the
boundary that is put on the man as a
Jewish woman a Jewish woman cannot even
get a divorce yeah and you know I just
want you to highlight one more thing and
this is for the farai to really
understand this point and I want them to
actually address this challenge what
exactly happened when American soldiers
and British soldiers landed in Germany
to German girls this is something a lot
of people don't talk about so if we're
going to talk about immigration and the
judeo-christian worldview and this and
this and this well we have the Americans
we have the British both Anglo-Saxon
inspired Nations going into Germany
another white nation and what are they
doing to the girls in the countryside
what are they doing to the French girls
and this is something that's been
documented so if you want to talk about
immigration and the link between
immigration and grooming gangs and rape
and sexual violence you cannot ignore
just like you ignored an entire
continent of data you cannot ignore the
data of mass rape and this is something
that these people will never be able to
address exactly i k watching this it's
very simple and what they did in
Afghanistan and
Iraq the rap 50% of the people in
concentration camps you know what let me
tell you this year this whole grooming
rape Etc all this kind of situation this
is your culture this is your culture
this is your problem pedophilia is your
problem this is happening in all these
Western World the Western World men who
are traveling to Thailand even African
countries to rape boys and little girls
it's men I'm so sorry if there's anyone
if they were to say if it's a the
prophet of a pedophile a the the profile
it's you a middle-aged white man if you
think about you are the problem you you
men are the one and I'm not saying every
single one but I'm saying if you're
going to go down that route this is what
you guys are doing and not only that
these men who were grooming or doing
whatever for that matter there was the
white corporates and those who are from
the Asian background whatever is for
that matter they were using what drugs
alcal music all from your culture man
this is your culture adopted your
culture to be very fair and direct we as
Muslims would never ever say it's the
people of it's white people it's it's
Christian people we would never say that
because we know this we know there's a
whole bunch of causal links which are
not linked to race or religion so we are
not doing what you're doing we're not
playing your dirty game but what you
have to realize is you have already lost
your credibility over many many years
for Shilling for the Zionist now you're
trying to prop up a dead narrative
through data which has missing links and
that is simply not going to work it's
not I mean that's it we don't need to
waste enough time on this clown he's
already slowly losing it uh brother and
sisters that's inah hope you guys have
benefited from this till next time